I got into the Air Force because I was
romanticizing that whole idea you know
we were refighting World War two as I
was growing up so we had all these
heroic movies and I fell in love with
the idea of flying and then when I got
into the Air Force
I had just big eye-opener that racism
was rampant there also and I not suited
for military life that kind of
unquestioning obedience to a lot of
things that I think of stupid didn't
quite go over well so when I got out I
was I was an early discharge it was
almost dishonorable you know because I
just really didn't fit but the catalyst
actually was in a jet trainer you had a
lot of people behind me to get me into
flight school and stuff but sitting
there it occurred to me that this is
absolutely not what I want it's it isn't
movies it's for real these you know this
little red button on a joystick controls
guns with real bullets and I'm sick I
said that for quite a while and knew so
I got out of that plane on the runway at
North Island Air Station a Naval Air
Station and I walked away from that and
towards acting I knew that it was all
about the movies it was all about the
movies your job as an actress to give it
your best shot each every time so yes
I'm going into it with the idea that
I'll play it to the best of my ability
and they wouldn't give it to me the role
if they didn't think I was capable of
pulling it off oh I wouldn't take it if
I didn't think I was capable of pulling
it off you just watched two amazing
clips of Morgan Freeman take the next
three minutes to sit quietly and think
about how you can apply them to your
business and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]